[Música]
cada ser humano comienza de la misma
manera dos células una de cada
progenitor que se encuentran mutuamente
y se convierten en una y aquella única
célula reproducida en sí misma se divide
y se divide y vuelve a dividirse hasta
convertirse en 10 billones de ellas pero
aquellos 10 billones de células no están
simplemente allí apiladas entonces qué
es lo que demuestra que una nariz es una
nariz y que los dedos del pie son dedos
del pie qué es lo que demuestra que esto
es un hueso Y esto es el cerebro y esto
es el corazón y esto esa cosa pequeñita
en la parte de atrás de la garganta cuyo
nombre jamás puedes recordar todo lo que
eres comienza con diminutas conexiones
de instrucciones establecidas en una y
en cada una de las células Entonces cómo
una célula contiene toda esa
información volvámonos pequeños entonces
podemos tomar un viaje al interior de
una sola célula para descubrir qué es lo
que constituye el libro sobre ti tu
genoma lo primero que vemos es que el
genoma completo todo tu ADN está
contenido dentro de su propio diminuto
compartimento denominado el núcleo si
extendemos todo el ADN en esta única
célula dentro de un solo hilo tendría
casi un metro de largo tenemos que
hacerlo caber en un diminuto
compartimento que es un millón de veces
más pequeño primero el largo hglo de ADN
envuelve a las proteínas en Der redor
agrupándolas dentro de pequeñas cuentas
denominadas núcleos somas y este collar
está envuelto en su propio espiral como
un cordón de teléfono antiguo y aquellos
espirales se disponen en capas unos
sobre otros hasta que obtenemos unas
pequeñas e impecables formas que caben
dentro del núcleo vaya 91 cm de ADN
apretujados en un pequeñísimo
compartimento cada diminuto grupo de ADN
es denominado cromosoma el libro sobre
ti tendría 46 capítulos uno por cada
cromosoma 23 capítulos de tu libro
provienen de tu mamá y 23 capítulos
provienen de tu papá dos de aquellos
capítulos denominados x y y determinan
si eres varón x y o mujer XX lo juntamos
y tendremos dos casi idénticos pero
ligeramente diferentes colecciones de 23
capítulos las minúsculas variaciones es
lo que hace diferente a cada persona se
estima que todos los capítulos juntos
contienen cerca de 20,000 instrucciones
individuales denominadas genes escritas
todas esas 20,000 instrucciones
equivalen a una extensión de 30 millones
de letras bien cada página de
instrucciones tiene unas pocas páginas
de incoherencias insertadas que tienen
que ser retiradas antes de acabar en
algo inútil a las partes que echamos
fuera las denominamos intrones las
instrucciones que conservamos las
denominamos exones podemos además tener
cientos de páginas en en medios de cada
Gen algunas de esas páginas excedentes
Fueron insertadas por pequeñas y
desagradables infecciones de nuestros
antepasados sin embargo algunas de ellas
son Realmente provechosas protegen a los
finales de cada capítulo de sufrir daño
o algunas ayudan a nuestras células a
encontrar aquellos que buscan en
particular en términos generales por
cada página de instrucciones hay casi
100 páginas de relleno finalmente cada
uno de los 46 capítulos de nuestros
libros tienen una extensión de entre 48
y 250 millones de letras aquello
equivale a
3.2000 millones de letras en total y el
libro tendría una extensión de más de
600,000 páginas cada tipo de célula
Porta el mismo libro pero cada uno tien
un conjunto de marcadores que indican
exactamente Cuáles páginas se necesitan
consultar por lo tanto cada celulita en
nuestro cuerpo está sosteniendo a un
asombroso libro lleno de instrucciones
para la vida tu nariz Lee páginas de
narices los dedos de tus pies leen
páginas de dedos del pies y esa cosita
en la parte de atrás de tu garganta
también tiene sus propias páginas bajo
el nombre de úvula
[Música]